je m'appelle aux geeks ullmann si tu
regarde de travers fait pas attention tu
es le plus déterminé de toute l'école je
sais que tu n'aimes pas toujours les
moyens d'abord j'adore le sache comment
vis tu n'es pas y est tu dis ça juste
parce que tu es ma mère est parce que je
suis ta mère que ça compte plus parce
que je suis celle qui te connais venir
[Musique]
tous une standing ovation au moins une
fois dans notre vie
c'est le cas de musique
les professeurs
soeur qui a toujours été là pour moi
mon père qui est cette
jour de me faire rigoler
et surtout à la main
s'ils n'abandonnent bien
les personnes particulièrement
belga
[Musique]